[Music]
one of my favorite things is when
conspiracy theories
conflict and you put the conspiracy
theorists
together to argue over which of their
conspiracies
is correct and of course none of them
are correct and if you want to see this
happen there's really no shortage of
options you can put two flat earthers
together to talk about
how they can prove the earth is flat
they will often have explanations
that conflict with each other they can't
both be true
you put anti-vaxxers together one will
tell you oh the covet vaccine can't be
trusted
because it was developed too quickly new
technology
not tested another will tell you it
can't be trusted because it's part of a
long-term
mind control project to control the
population through vaccines
it's been in planning for decades
they've been waiting for a pandemic to
justify its use wait wait a second hold
on
is the problem that it's a long planned
population control device or that they
just came up with this in a few months
and put it out there
they can't they're conflicting
explanations it's
a just entertaining to see i have a
great example for you
today which i love during our vacation
early in the week
my pillow ceo mike lindell told steve
bannon
on his war room show that donald trump
is going to be back in office
now it's in august because of some new
lawsuit who the hell knows
but then in the middle of the same week
a televangelist
named nathan french says god told
him trump is coming back in april
so which is it a perfect show
would be mike lindell and nathan french
arguing is trump going back to being
president
in april or is trump going back in
august and of course
he's not coming back in either joe biden
is president so check this out we'll
start with mike lindell
explaining the august hypothesis what
i'm talking about steve
is what i have been doing since january
9th all the evidence i have
everything is going to go before the
supreme court
and the election of 2020 is going
bye-bye
i it was an attack by another country
communism coming in
i don't know what they're going to do
with what after they pull it down but
it's
hang on hang on
so none of that is true nothing that
mike lindell is doing is going to be
going to go before the supreme court the
2020 election is not going to be
going bye-bye communism didn't come in
and trump will not be back in august but
here is nathan french totally different
trump will be back in april trump will
be back
this month here's nathan french's
explanation man i said he was gonna win
big and he didn't win and the lord says
yes he did
and and so you have to recognize that he
actually won
with a landslide victory and a lot of
people don't get that
they tried to steal the election and
it's not going to work god's about to
lay it bare
and god's not saying uh look
you know he won big i know he went big
so be satisfied with that put on
a good attitude and let's move forward i
told you he's going to win big he did
win big now get over it
he's not saying that no no no it's not
over he's about to lay it bare
january february march i think we're
going to find out in april i think
everything's gonna change
i see a shift i mean i i feel like the
people are waiting to see
when is the god of justice gonna step in
you're already seeing some of the things
you know on the news and
i don't want to get into too much of
that because there are certain things i
i can't really say there's a lot of
stuff i i know
so this guy says it's actually april
when all will be
laid bare to use his vocabulary so of
course they're both wrong and after
august comes and goes it would be just
as interesting to put them both in a
room together to explain
why were you wrong about april and why
were you wrong about
august and i'm sure they would disagree
about why it hasn't happened as well
now one of the things that is
interesting here is comparing and
contrasting the sort of psyche of these
two guys
are they merely con men using different
techniques to con their audiences are
they
mentally ill in the sense that they're
delusional
in a diagnostic sense do they really
believe they are talking to
god in the sense that this is mostly a
religious thing i actually can't tell
nathan french seems more like a guy who
literally believes the religious stuff
that leads him to thinking he is
speaking to god
some would say that is a delusion mike
lindell
strikes me more like as a half con man
but also not connected to reality in
what may be a diagnostic situation
or maybe related to you know some people
have talked about substance abuse or
something else
it's really difficult to tell where this
is
on the sc what is the scale even full
con
to full delusional and maybe in the
middle of someone who
saying i i don't know if i believe this
but i kind of feel okay bringing it to
people because it's making money
i don't know i don't know but let me
know what you think the parameters are
what is the scale on which we analyze
these people
and where on the scale do you think
nathan french
and mike lindell fall they're both wrong
factually
but their underlying motivations are
certainly an interesting thing to think
about